do you you don't mike stutt at all
oh of course yeah i love mike yeah
mike's my boy he'll be out here uh shoot
next week but oh [ __ ] he's a another guy
similar to you where he's been you know
preaching independent all the time and
they've thrown some bags i'm saying i'm
good i'm keep doing it myself
but you you signed with me i did well i
worked out a really good partnership
with the company i just you know what i
had a moment of clarity for one
i can only talk about this so much
because of a non-disclosure agreement
you signed with daily wire right yeah
that's exactly how did you know
um
i kept i kept ownership of my masters
which is huge it's huge i kept
a hundred percent of my publishing still
i kept the lion's share of the streaming
revenue and i mean like
if this would be like a [ __ ] floyd
mayweather marquez fight one kind of
deal yeah like right that's probably the
most diplomatic way i can say it when i
get myself in trouble
so and so what's in it for them though
just well you
i think can only be on their network i
was lucky
that the president of the company
just really believed in doing different
stuff that's cool so his thing was like
look i know i'm not going to make a lot
of money off you and that it's going to
be more than it's worth
but i he's into he's into legacy [ __ ]
yeah he's a dude that's like changing
the face of country music like this
record label is called broken bow
records uh you all know nothing about
country music i'm sure but i'll give you
the briefing of it jason aldean chen
knows yeah i know the flagship is there
huge alden's the big one
but like jimmy allen's one of their
artists which is like crushing you know
a black dude that dresses like a pimp
and bowls every day and it's like yeah
not what you would think it's like
american idol yeah y'all would y'all
would love each other it's like not what
you think would be a country artist
blanco brown who had that real big song
put your hair down yeah then who's that
took it number one at country radio
um laney wilson who's like this hippie
bell bottom wearing chick that sings
country music like their whole thing is
painting outside of the lines like they
don't want to be like hey give me a big
tall handsome dude with a cowboy hat
that grew up in cheyenne wyoming with a
big country song like give me a dude
that yeah yeah right yeah they're like
give me a dude that does not look like
he belongs here
and let's make it work so i just kind of
lucky for me jonathan loba and adrian
meatball michaels were like
yeah dude we're into this different [ __ ]
because all these labels wanted to put
me in like pop they were like yo what if
we get you a song with charlie puth and
i was like i'm not interested i was like
i was like i want to play the grand ole
opry i'm from nashville yeah you know
what i mean like i want to you know
so finally and then i'd go to the record
labels and that's when they were like
hold on
you want us to take a dude with a
nickname a criminal record face tattoos
and permanent gold teeth and put out a
rock and roll or a country record
they're like get the [ __ ] out of here
and this dude was like yeah no problem
we're going to take you straight where
you want to go there goes gretel out for
debut damn it was incredible they did it
they told me they were going to do it
and they did it this is the record label
yeah yeah so it's like when they came in
i said look i just kind of like you i'm
like i've got
all of the i make my own music write my
own songs produce my own records shoot
my own videos put my own content out i
just need you to give me the stuff that
i can't get as an independent correct
right
can you get me the radio yeah can you
get me to kimmel yep you know what i
mean like my publicist i got to publish
this for the first time in my life when
i came to la
she couldn't book me nothing because i
booked myself yeah with the stuff i
wanted to do i was like yo shout out
she's awesome though she did camel right
she's doing her job she's doing great oh
yeah so she's uh but she's like yo do
you want to do this and i was like oh no
i'm sorry if you you don't understand
i'm with the homies like yeah i'm like a
comedian in spirit i'm going to see shop
you hook me up with bird i'm gonna go
see bird you know what i'm saying i got
my own i got a circuit here i was like
i'll be all right i'm cool yeah with
those people i had a for my special i
was gonna hire a pr firm
and then i go okay what can you do for
me i'm like all right well tell us what
you already have and i gave them this
list i was like these are all my boys
that's what i have
and what can you do like we cannot beat
that no there's nothing the purposes are
tough that way like my manager like no
matter what he books what no matter what
my agent books they only get 10 of it
but they only get paid if i get that
ninety percent you know
whereas the publicist just takes five
grand and goes uh yeah we got nothing
for this month like well you didn't do
anything and i still gotta pay you like
yes that's different thing yeah i think
well i don't think this is my thing yeah
they get paid for effort they get paid
for effort they can say well we really
reached out to a lot of people yeah they
make you feel bad yeah nobody wanted you
[ __ ] i'm getting cold yeah